[Applause]
[Music]
when the stars are burning
out and the waves are crashing in
running circles in my mind got me
searching for a light that can guide me
home again when I'm in a
hurricane
and the water sto to rise while the
lonely and the Thunder want to try and
take me under but I'm swim against the
tide and I've been caught in Stormy
Weather but nothing last forever morning
Sunrise going to remind me I still got
good friends that I never met and some
Big Dreams that I'm trying to catch and
memories that I want to get but I still
ain't got to make M simple life that I
want to live and lot of love that I got
to give and couple checks off the bucket
list that I still ain't got to make so
when I think my B is going to
break I hold on to the hope of Better
Days
so when I'm drifting in the
deep and I'm looking for
someone oh you always there to find me
just in time to remind me The Best Is
Yet To Come CU I've got good friends
that I never met and Big Dreams that I'm
trying to catch and memories that I want
to get but I still ain't got to make
it's
simple life that I want to live lot of
love that I got to give couple checks
off the bucket list that I still ain't
got to make so when I think my B is
going to
break I hold on to the hope of living in
the M instead of drowning in the
past CU time it keeps on
rolling got to learn to make it
last I still got good friends that I
never met and some Big Dreams that I'm
trying to catch and some memories that I
want to get and I know I'm about to make
it's a simple life that I want to live a
whole lot of love that I got to give
couple checks off The Bucket List just
can't wait to
make so when I think my B is going to
break I hold on to the hope of better
days better
days oh better
[Music]
days all right once more let's hear
for on his new album Better
[Music]
[Applause]
music thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home